[Music]
well our daily cancellation today begins
with a woman named joe lumen who uh
identifies herself as a pastor and a
theologian
that'll prove to be as we'll see an
absurd
self-identification even by today's
standards it's still pretty absurd in
her twitter bio joe describes herself
her mission this way she says
decolonizing faith and spirituality
dismantling oppression and toxic
theology she goes by she they pronouns
by the way in case you were interested
and she is also on the board of
directors as a parent board trustee of a
charter school in san diego called the
elevate school and that last detail her
status as a parent board trustee is
especially disturbing and you'll soon
see why if you don't already see it in
any case it would appear that um
yesterday joe was playing in some kind
of game show where contestants are
challenged to compose and then post the
most inflammatory stupid morally vacuous
tweet they possibly can we can assume
that she took home the million dollar
prize with this effort she tweeted
i would rather get an abortion than have
a brown child who ends up being adopted
by white evangelicals it's not a
kindness to children of the global
majority to give them to people who will
traumatize them with self and ancestral
hatred in abortion is an act of love
yes joe thinks it's better for a black
child to be killed
than adopted by white parents
bad news for colin kaepernick and for
many millions of other people who
according to joe would be better off
dead
and notice how quickly the narrative
shifted from pro-lifers are hypocrites
who oppose abortion but refuse to adopt
children to now
pro-lifers are colonizers who adopt
children quick let's kill all the babies
before they get a chance
there's more to say here but first let's
review the entire exchange that followed
um i responded to joe's tweet in my
usual subtle gentle fashion writing
so you're a racist along with being a
homicidal soulless baby killing ghoul
got it thanks
joe immediately sends the opportunity to
make herself the victim and she wrote
back no not this
quote tweeting me i'm literally freaking
out about about the hatred i'm about to
get for sharing my own choice and i
won't be silenced i won't delete my post
i stand by what i said
a few minutes later she posted again
emphasizing the point i'm genuinely
panicking last time a conservative like
ali beth stucky and matt walsh tweeted
me i got death threats with my address
and the names of my children and i won't
be silenced but i'm begging them to
please tell their followers to be decent
be decent she cries
cries the woman specifically who just
said she'd rather suck her child's
brains out of his skull
that allow him to live with a white
family
be decent damn you
can you see that decency is her highest
priority
well her first priority is keeping her
children away from races she despises
even if that requires her to kill and
dismember them but after that she really
cares about the whole decency thing
now joe's fellow blue czech feminist
came to her aid including a woman named
jen morrison who's a freelance writer
for the new york times and other outlets
as well she commented
you might consider locking your account
just for a little bit
i watched walsh encourage his followers
to continue attacking a suicidal woman
they aren't relentless i'm so sorry
now it's true that the sweet baby gang
is relentless but nothing else she said
approaches the vicinity of the truth i
of course have never told anybody to
attack a suicidal woman in fact i've
never encouraged anyone to attack anyone
so i asked jen to produce evidence
screenshot clip something
to back up her defamatory claim about me
but jen informed me that she doesn't
want to mention the name of my alleged
victim or produce evidence that this
event occurred because that would be
really painful for the woman so we just
have to take her word for it
as somebody in the comments pointed out
this is like the feminist twitter
version of yeah i totally have a
girlfriend but she goes to a different
school
except with an added dose of defamation
towards me in this case
okay now
a few points
first
this is the leftist mo right most
especially the feminist leftist mo a
tale as old as time
empowered feminist woman says something
utterly vile and insane people on the
internet point out that it's vile and
insane
empowered feminist woman immediately
becomes a fainting damsel in distress
crying that she's being attacked and her
feelings are hurt
we might dub this the taylor lorenz
maneuver and a vital part of this
maneuver of course is to claim that
you're getting death threats but to
never produce a single screenshot of any
of those threats
it's very nice of these ladies too i
guess i mean they're getting thousands
of death threats but they respect the
privacy of the people threatening them
with death so they don't post the
screenshots like ever they just never do
they never produce any evidence of any
of these they're getting death threats
every day we never see any of them
i mean you would think if people are
sending you death threats um you'd have
a lot of incentive to post it and like
put their name out there and everything
and i
i don't know i guess they're just being
very considerate
second it's true that my initial
response to joe was um
quite aggressive let's just say and uh
and insulting as well i mean i did call
her a ghoul after all and in a follow-up
tweet i also called her a goblin
and really any monstrous creature from
fantasy novels could work here ghoul
goblin troll vampire werewolf i mean
whatever you want to do
um
the comparison works in any of those
cases but but but should i especially as
a christian
be speaking to and about people this way
that's the question and the answer is
yes
absolutely i should and so should you
it's essential that we do not allow
ourselves to become numb to evil
we have to see it for what it is and
respond to it accordingly this woman
said out loud
that she would rather kill her children
than let a loving white family adopt
them
that's not simply an opposing viewpoint
it's not just an opinion it's not just
like some idea it is pure unadulterated
evil
it's just about the worst thing a human
being could possibly say or think
and my fear is that living in this
twisted culture where where you know
evil straight from the bowels of hell
has been normalized and mainstream we
may not have the kind of gut level
emotional reaction to it that we ought
to have
and that's why we should respond harshly
and severely
here's another good rule of thumb got a
lot of them
when you hear someone on the left say
something disgusting and psychotic
imagine how people 70 years ago would
have responded to that statement and
respond like they would have responded
third and final point
joe says she wants to decolonize faith
well this is ironic because of course
she's doing exactly the opposite
to colonize something is to establish
political control over it
so leftists are engaged in a kind of
ideological colonization attempting to
establish
ideological control
over countries institutions cultures and
religions especially christianity
you know they hang the pride flag on
embassies and countries that have no
interest in lgbt pride they force gender
neutrality into foreign languages that
are inherently gendered
they insist that everything conform to
their ideology and they pervert and
corrupt christianity in attempt to turn
it into not just a different faith but
into its own opposite
joe and her comrades envision a
christianity where the self not christ
sits at the center the highest love is
self-love
in their version of christianity
anything done for the sake of the self
is good abortion is an act of love she
says and she means that it's an act of
love for the self because it is service
to the self
she flips christianity on its head
makes it into satanism
and then accuses everybody else of
colonizing faith
but that's exactly what she is doing of
course well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the matt wall show if you did go
ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content